hi there my name is bradley knapp and
i'm with ibm cloud and the question that
i want to answer for you guys today is
what is a lamp stack so we've gotten
some questions and comments in the past
we've had people approach us and they
say hey
i hear this referenced all the time i
have absolutely no idea what a lamp
stack is this is not something i'm
familiar with and so
lamp is an acronym it stands for linux
apache mysql in
php and it is the stack of software
that at its most fundamental makes the
internet run
and i know that seems kind of bizarre
and kind of an outlandish claim but i
can assure you that the internet exists
in the form that we use today in the
form that we consume it today because of
the lamp stack and so first i want to go
through like what are those components
and then we're going to talk about how
they work
so
if we think about running a website
right
in order to run a website you have to
have some sort of a server
now
that server
could be a physical server it could be a
virtual server
it could be in a data center it could be
running in cloud it could be in a colo
facility it could be just
a laptop that's plugged into your room
but you have to have some sort of a
computer hardware
to run that website you have to have
something that is turned on and has
electricity and network access
and then on top of that hardware you
have the four lamp components right the
first one that we're going to talk about
here
is our linux
linux is the free open source software
that is an operating system it's
community supported it's community
developed and linux is that operating
system that forms most of the internet
it is the underlying operating system of
the internet writ large
and linux comes in lots of different
flavors right you've got
pure linux if you will so the pure linux
kernel you have ubuntu from canonical
you have red hat you have susa you have
centos you have mint
all different flavors but all using the
same underlying kernel or close enough
that it really doesn't matter but again
it's free it's freely distributed
anybody can go out and download it
compile it install it and get it running
that's the l all right our next piece in
our lamp stack is our a a is apache
apache again free open source software
from the apache foundation apache is the
web server layer so apache software that
you install onto your linux operating
system onto the server
and the point of apache is to be able to
understand
all of those incoming network requests
what do they mean and what do i send
back when i'm done so apache is the
actual web server itself if you want to
think about the web server being its own
standalone software
and then the next piece
that's rm
lam
and rm is for mysql
mysql is a free open source sql
structured query language database again
free open source community developed
community supported so anybody can go
down install or download it compile it
install it and run it
and the idea behind mysql is it is the
database layer for your lamp stack it's
the database for your website well what
is a database a database has tables in
it inside the tables we store data and
so if you think about going to a website
where you're going to log in right that
website prompts you for credentials it
wants your username and your password
before you could
log into it you had to register for it
you had to give it your name your
address your telephone number your email
address so on and so forth all of that
data that you input goes into this
database and so when you log in it's
going to go and it's going to check
against the database to say hey does
this username match does this password
match so that's the database that's
where all of the data that is dynamic is
housed
and then our fourth rp and this goes
down here at the bottom
we've got all of our components how do
we write the site well we need a
language and that's what php is for php
is the most commonly used language in
running websites building websites
php is again it is free it is community
written it is community supported
anybody can download it anybody can
compile it and anybody can install it
php is far and away the most common
language used for scripting or writing
websites
and so
that's a description these are the
components of the lamp stack let's talk
about how do they work
and so let's imagine
a guy
this guy
he's smiling
we'll give him a little smile he's got a
laptop right so his laptop
he wants to get onto it he wants to go
to your website and so he's going to
send a request
down here to
your server that's running
lamp
and he's going to say hey
please send me your front page
and so that request that's going to come
in let me uh let's do our l a m p here
so that request that's going to come in
the the request is going to be hey
please send this to me so it's going to
come in it's going to hit the apache and
say hey this guy wants the website
apache is going to say all right well we
need to send it out so let me run the
code the php to
send html back so that it knows what to
display
let me access that m the mysql database
to say hey what data are we going to
send back is there anything in the
database we're going to send or is it
all static or hard coded
and it's going to talk to the l to the
linux and say hey operating system this
incoming request it's good to go and
we're going to send this data back to
him we're going to send back the code
we're going to send back the data and
we're going to send it back in this web
compliant standard method and so it is
then going to transmit those via packets
back to our guy with our laptop and he's
going to be able to view the website
everything that he clicks on
is going to generate a new series of
communications back and forth between
his laptop and the server running the
lamp stack to serve up all of the images
to serve up the text to serve up the
prompts anything that moves anything
that's intelligent
the underlying components are exactly
the same
and so you'll see other videos on this
channel that talk about other kinds of
web servers
lamp is far and away the longest serving
it is the most popular it's the one
that's been around the longest
and it really doesn't matter what web
framework you're going to use at the end
of the day the underlying architecture
depends on the exact same things that we
scripted at 15 years ago when the lamp
stack was originally developed
and so hopefully that's been good
information for you as always if you
have any questions please feel free to
put them into the comments i do actually
try and come in and answer them somebody
else from ibm be able to answer them if
you want to get really in depth please
reach out to your ibm team and we'll see
what we can do to help you out
thank you so much for stopping by the
channel today if you have any questions
or comments please feel free to share
them with us below if you enjoyed this
video and you would like to see more
like it in the future please do like the
video and subscribe to us so that we'll
know to keep creating for you